it's the iconic my neighbor totoro a
character so famous days actually the
icon for studio ghibli a big hit in
japan and even growing a cult following
in america the - good talk around this
movie is so big that a lot of people
actually end up kind of not liking it
and I can see why it's built up so much
and this image is so popular that anyone
going in thinking they're gonna see the
spectacular big story is probably gonna
be really disappointed luckily when I
went in I had no expectations whatsoever
I just got it from a friend saying hey
this is a good movie check it out I did
and that's pretty much what I thought -
it was a good movie not great but I
don't think it's supposed to be great I
think it's supposed to be just a fun
little flick why there's such an
explosion over it I don't know maybe
people just like the sort of smaller
flicks and want to get it more attention
to a point where it's actually exploded
into this giant franchise it's kind of
like how a Christmas story has but for
what it is I like it fine the stories
about a family that moves into a new
home there's a father a mother and two
little daughters played by the Fanning
sisters but they discover something very
interesting about this home apparently
there's spirits all over the place in
any other movie this would probably be a
scary thing but the family just kind of
accepts it and says hi sometimes the
spirits say hi back but most the time
they just keep in hiding and wouldn't
you know it one of them is a giant koala
cat turu thing known as Totoro he
doesn't exactly do much he just kind of
sleeps takes the bus he can fly that's
kind of cool
and he has absolutely no dialogue
outside of one or two roars and that's
about it
really that's the movie it's just sort
of watching these girls interact with
the spirit and them getting used to
moving to a new location and or whatever
reason it kind of works and don't get me
wrong there's still some incredible
imagery in this the backgrounds are
wonderful there's this cat bus thing
that's now become world-famous
and
the flying scenes are very nice but if
you were to ask me what happens scene by
scene like an order of the story I
couldn't tell you that is to say stuff
does happen you see them trying to get
used to being displays and interacting
with boys and so on so forth but the
story's not really the focus the focus
is more character and atmosphere the
casting of the Fanning sisters was a
very clever call as they weren't very
naturally off each other they don't act
like Co actors or even just friends they
feel like sisters something about that
camaraderie and the way they work off
each other it's pretty solid the rest of
the voice acting is pretty good too so
not a ton is required of it it's still
pretty effective it's kind of like
spending a really laid-back Sunday
outside with some friends maybe coming
across a weird animal trying to interact
with it playing around getting dirty
coming home and going to sleep that's
kind of the movie but again that's kind
of childhood - isn't it kind of those
fun summer days where you could just
sort of do whatever you want you're out
of school and I don't know that's how I
see this movie it's just kind of a
really fun yet laid-back summer when
you're a little kid
there's fun music and goofiness but
there's also a lot of quiet moments of
just a character looking at another
character or just taking the other end
now there's something actually really
charming about it
no no maybe that's kind of a strange
fascination with the film that
absolutely nothing can happen on screen
and yet you're still kind of sucked into
it there's a whole scene where one of
the sisters just sits on top of Totoro
and that's it there's an R scene where
the other sister just waits for a bus
with Totoro and that's it
yet something about the way it's paced
and animated and delivered it feels very
alive somehow you don't feel like you're
being manipulated or that this is lazy
you look like you're watching something
kind of cool not spectacular but kind of
cool and the film allows you to take in
this small bit of wonder well it's not
big it still allows you to take in the
full amount you soak in the scene you
remember the feelings you remember the
expressions if stuff like that doesn't
do it for you
looking for something that's a lot more
story-based then you're probably not
gonna have a good time with this granted
there is a dilemma in the last third of
the film but it almost feels a little
forced and in some ways not needed like
the film just needed some kind of climax
buts nowhere near so contrived that
ruins anything you still want to see
everything turn out okay and stick with
these characters well yeah don't expect
a lot of action or a lot of wonder or a
lot of story but just expect a small
amount to be satisfied I think that's
part of the charm of Miyazaki's films
you had this art form of animation
anything you can draw and suddenly exist
and yet they use it to tell the story of
only a few fantastical things and focus
more on the human characters something
about keeping it so minimal actually
makes you appreciate what's on screen
even more at least from my point of view
I don't know I even heard there's like
any kind of backlash for this film but
I've definitely heard of people that
watched it and just didn't get what it
was all about and I can understand that
there is so much build-up for this movie
the image is shown all over the place
hell it's even in Toy Story be looking
for more of a relaxed film that you can
pop in and just sort of enjoy the
atmosphere of you'll find it to be
pretty charming pretty creative and just
the right amount of entertaining I
personally don't see it as one of my
favorites I don't even know if I put it
in one Miyazaki's top 5 but it's still
good and there's a lot of effort that's
put into it it's small it's simple but
who says there's anything wrong with
that
you